normalmente cuando pensamos en el adn
pensamos en el núcleo de una célula y
eso se debe a que el adn de una célula
está contenido en su núcleo pero en
realidad hay algunas excepciones a esta
regla general hay ciertos organelos que
de hecho tienen su propio adn y dos
ejemplos muy famosos de estos son las
mitocondrias y los cloroplastos las
mitocondrias y los cloroplastos tienen
su propio adn que voy a garabatear aquí
en azul y no solo tienen su propio adn
sino que también pueden replicarlo y
replicarse a sí mismos
independientemente del núcleo de la
célula en la que se encuentran
hablemos brevemente sobre las
mitocondrias las mitocondrias son estos
organelos que se encuentran en las
células eucariotas y a veces se les
conoce como el centro energético de la
célula porque descomponen la glucosa
para producir esta molécula de alta
energía llamada atp y luego la célula
toma este atp y lo usa para todo tipo de
procesos celulares y el adn mitocondrial
escrito como adn mt tiene alrededor de
37 genes y la mayoría de estos genes
tienen que ver con la respiración
celular que ocurre en
londres hablemos un poco sobre los
cloroplastos los cloroplastos son estos
organelos que se encuentran en las
células vegetales también se encuentran
en las células de algas y los
cloroplastos son el sitio donde ocurre
la fotosíntesis si quisiéramos ser más
específicos tenemos estas pilas llamadas
grano bien en singulares granos en
plural es grana y estos granos están
formados por estos pequeños círculos
llamados ty la coidh es y la
fotosíntesis ocurre dentro de estos ty
la coidh es durante la fotosíntesis la
luz solar se aprovecha por supuesto
además de un montón de otros pasos para
producir glucosa de aquí proviene el
concepto de hacer su propia comida en
realidad están haciendo glucosa están
haciendo su propia comida y luego esa
glucosa va a las mitocondrias de esa
célula se descompone produce atp y luego
la célula usa de ese atp para lo que sea
que tenga que hacer el adn en el cloro
plast oa veces llamado adn cp tiene
alrededor de 100 genes y la mayoría de
estos genes tienen que ver con proteínas
o cosas que están involucradas en la
fotosíntesis
y la razón por la que esto es
interesante es porque si vemos cómo se
lleva a cabo normalmente la reproducción
sexual tenemos un óvulo y el núcleo de
ese óvulo tiene sólo la mitad de la
cantidad de adn que tendría una célula
normal en ese organismo
llamamos a eso m y luego tenemos un
espermatozoide recuerden que el
espermatozoide es mucho mucho más
pequeño que un óvulo esto no está
dibujado a escala y el espermatozoide
también tiene en su núcleo sólo la mitad
de la cantidad de adn que normalmente
tienen las células en este organismo
esto también es m pero luego se fusionan
para hacer un cigoto y este cigoto es 2n
tiene la cantidad normal de adn que
tendría una célula de este organismo la
mitad proviene del óvulo y la otra mitad
proviene del espermatozoide y este
cigoto se dividirá en dos células y esas
dos células se dividirán en más y esto
seguirá y seguirá hasta que sean
suficientes células para formar un
organismo pero este óvulo es una célula
completamente desarrollada y no sólo
tiene información genética también tiene
organelos en el citoplasma tiene estas
mitocondrias
plasma y esas mitocondrias tienen adn
que sólo voy a garabatear un poco de
azul en el interior y estos cigotos
también tienen estas mitocondrias porque
recordemos que el cigoto es
prácticamente un óvulo con la única
diferencia en que su núcleo tiene el adn
adicional del espermatozoide y
recordemos que el espermatozoide no dona
nada al óvulo excepto la mitad del adn
en el núcleo no le da al cigoto nada más
tenemos esos cigotos con estas
mitocondrias y por supuesto tienen su
adn y luego cuando este cigoto se
replica entonces replica el núcleo pero
también replica las mitocondrias en el
citoplasma voy a omitir el núcleo solo
estoy dibujando las mitocondrias así que
tengo estas mitocondrias pero estas
mitocondrias provienen solo del óvulo
ninguna de estas mitocondrias proviene
de los espermatozoides esto nos lleva al
concepto de herencia materna que bueno
es exactamente como suena es una
herencia que ocurre solo desde la línea
materna o sólo desde el óvulo entonces
aquí estamos demostrando que las
mitocondrias que este organismo
finalmente tendrá se origina en las
mitocondrias que provienen
el óvulo y no del espermatozoide y por
lo tanto exhibe herencia materna así que
tanto las mitocondrias como los
cloroplastos exhiben herencia materna
porque están en el óvulo que después se
convertirá en el organismo y es
interesante notar que la herencia
materna es una herencia no mendeliana la
herencia materna es una herencia no
mendeliana porque la herencia mendeliana
supone que la mitad del adn proviene del
óvulo la mitad del espermatozoide y no
tiene en cuenta ningún tipo de
información genética que proviene de uno
solo de los gametos por ejemplo solo del
óvulo y de hecho todo lo que acabamos de
describir aquí puede denominarse
herencia extra nuclear
la herencia extra nuclear se referiría a
cualquier gen que se transmita desde las
estructuras que no están en el núcleo
extra nuclear significa fuera del núcleo
las mitocondrias y los cloroplastos
están fuera del núcleo cuando se heredan
nos referimos a ello como herencia extra
nuclear ahora que hemos introducido la
herencia extra nuclear daremos un
vistazo a uno de los primeros
experimentos que ayudaron a descubrir la
herencia extra nuclear